pas de baignade surveillée cet été au
lac des bretonnières de joué-lès-tours
la faute au taux de cyanobactérie trop
élevé la municipalité cherche une
solution technique pour éviter que cela
ne se reproduise car c'est la troisième
année consécutive que la piscine reste
fermé les cyanobactéries se développe en
cas de forte chaleur l'été dans des eaux
basses eaux stagnantes elles peuvent
causer des démangeaisons chez l'homme
mais également peuvent être mortelles
chez les animaux explications de samuel
collants
pour la troisième année pas de baignade
au bretonnière ses élèves de 6e
terminent leur année scolaire au bord de
l'eau sans plongeon cette fois ci tous
les ans la dernière semaine ans pour un
take two les sixièmes trois classes
c'était bien c'est vrai que c'est
dommage que ce club décision de la ville
de joué les tours le lac a déjà un taux
de cyanobactérie trop important les
habitants devront faire sans leurs
piscines naturelles l'été je m'en vais
pas forcément en vacances loin et du
coup c'était pratique quand on a des
enfants même quand on en a pas de venir
se tremper les pieds dans l'eau au moins
ces cyanobactéries sont présentes dans
l'eau toute l'année mais en cas de forte
chaleur elle se développe avec des
risques pour la santé plutôt des
démangeaisons des irritations cutanées
enfin dépens de également des
possibilités de trouvera notamment
gastro intestinaux au delà de la
baignade il ya également la consommation
de produits de la pêche
qui implique quasiment un baigneur des
risques aussi pour le meilleur ami de
l'homme plusieurs chiens décède tous les
étés en ingérant cette bactérie la
piscine naturelle de joué-lès-tours et
pour l'instant la seule concernée par
cette interdiction dans le département
quel que soit le lieu il est conseillé
d'éviter de toucher les algues et de se
doucher après la baignade mais sachez
qu'il y a quand même sept lieux de
baignade de baignade par don naturel
ouvert est surveillé en indre et loire à
chemillé hommes château la vallière ou
encore bourgueil pas de risque de lié
aux cyanobactéries en ce moment à deux
les prélèvements sont réguliers sur
chacun de ces sites